la música y poderoso
yo aprendí a tocar guitarra cuando tenía
11 años de forma perfecto el día en el
que empecé a tocar guitarra
era el día de la madre de 1990 mayor mi
papá había viajado semanas antes por
trabajo y fue fue allí cuando tuvo un
segundo impacto al corazón
mi mamá tuvo que viajar de emergencia el
día de la madre
de 1990 y mi prima pensó que iba a ser
una buena idea enseñarme a tocar
guitarra
para distraer un poco de todo el caos
que estaba sucediendo
entonces fue ese día cuando la reunida y
empecé a tocar mis primeros 13 cortes la
música tiene el poder de sanar
en mendhar de hacernos reflexionar el
poder de las palabras cuando tienen
música cambia por ejemplo si yo las
recitó un poema una parte del poema de
antonio machado que dice cuando el
relleno no puede cantar cuando el poeta
es un peregrino
cuando de nada nos sirve rezar caminante
no hay camino se hace camino al andar
lo que pasa si no se los canto
cuando el jilguero no puede encantar
cuando el poeta es un p
cuando de nada nos sirve besar
en el camino se hace camino al andar'
el mensaje
llegan directamente donde tiene que
llegar las palabras de gran fuerza una
vez que tienen melodías que tienen un
ritmo que seguir
por eso yo creo que la música tiene
superpoderes
qué sucede cuando pongamos un
instrumento cuando cantamos o
simplemente cuando estamos escuchando
música los niveles de dopamina
endorfinas y serotonina se elevan estos
son los químicos la gente a veces lo
llaman las drogas de la felicidad no
porque se producen en nuestro cerebro y
nos hace sentir bien los 60 y felices
conozco muchos médicos que tratan a
veces a sus pacientes y les mandan comer
un chocolate al día porque el chocolate
es antidepresivo por ende sube los
niveles de serotonina en el cerebro pero
qué pasa uno se come el chocolate y es
un pico y decae
pero cuando uno escucha música como es
por un tiempo prolongado
esto esto tiene que conseguir elevando y
se mantiene por eso la música tiene la
capacidad de relajarnos de alegrarnos de
motivarnos de inspirarnos
cuando llegó el momento
de decidir qué cosa yo estudiar tendría
16 17 años yo sabía que tenía que hacer
música
porque uno viene a este mundo a ser
feliz y si me voy a dedicar al
porque si no para que trabajaba
entonces yo decidí estudiar música y
cuando me preguntan si quieres estudiar
yo respondió a estudiar música
y me preguntaba y aparte de la música
o sea llevo 17 horas 17 créditos de
clases en la universidad la semana más
las 20.000 horas necesario que tengo que
tener no sé cómo que más crece deporte
la música
o te pregunten no pero vas a estudiar
algo más no por si acaso
y es como que a veces yo sintió que no
tenía aprendí entonces no sabía si en
verdad podía del internet de éstos y la
peor la que eso sí nunca le pueden ser
aún cantando el músico a firmarles que
les gusta el karaoke
soy form
yo trabajo de día educando música y en
las noches me dedico a hacer
presentaciones en vivo a cantar entonces
si yo tengo una noche libre
no sé si ustedes les les ha pasado que
están un poco inquietos sienten algo acá
en el pecho y no sabe inglés no pueden
poner el dedo no sabe qué es lo que les
está fastidiando porque hemos sabido que
los tiene tan inviernos
probablemente
escucha una canción y es como que sea
ramo del rompecabezas pasado
ese es el poder que tiene la música
yo a veces no sé qué me pasa con el
tráfico que tenemos acá en lima escucho
mucho más música de antes y hay veces en
que todo se resuelve como una sola
canción porque la música no solamente
un medio de expresión la forma de
expresión la música cantina es un medio
de comunicación y ahí es donde viene la
responsabilidad
una vez que yo descubrí que yo podía
escribir lo que pensaba en lo que sentía
sentí que tenía una gran responsabilidad
la responsabilidad
que uno tiene cuando se pare en un
escenario cuando tiene un micrófono
enfrente es llevar el mensaje a mí me
tocaba acompañar
distintos tipos de eventos celebraciones
y realmente la música acompaña
la música acompaña
uno debe transmitir
lo que se necesita transmitir en ese
momento
si estoy un cumpleaños es una
celebración entonces la emoción que debo
transmitir es la de la alegría si me
toca cantar en una misa por ejemplo de
meses
lo que yo tengo que transmitir ahí
es algo es un sentimiento reconfortante
envolver a la persona que sienten esta
tristeza en como un mensaje
reconfortante
para que puedan vivir su proceso de 10
minutos
la música en poder emotiva inspira y
además también es como la del tema
porque a mí me hace regresar a cuando
era niña hay canciones que me hacen
imaginar mi futuro
otras naciones que simplemente describen
el hoy
y es impresionante como como una sola
canción
yo he podido descubrir me en cada etapa
de mi vida
alejandro lerner compuso una canción
espectacular llamada todo pulmón
y cuando era niña
yo soñaba con estar en escenarios y
cantaban esa canción me daba
luego llegó el adolescencia y me di
cuenta que me tenía que mantener en este
viaje sin saber a dónde voy en realidad
luego me encontré con una realidad
tirada
ese río indicado
y cambió mi vida el cambio
luego me tocó defender mi ideología
y yo sabía que era para algunas personas
buenas para otras malas pero al final es
la mía y eso era lo que yo tenía que
vender
y encontrarme y sincerar y enfrentar al
mundo como soy un libro abierto con el
corazón en la mano todas esas cosas
pasan por mi cabeza una sudoración
y todavía tengo la fuerza desde el todo
la música nos sirve para controlar
emociones y alavés para desbordar las
muchas veces es necesario desbordar las
sobre todo cuando no tienen alguna
inquietud a veces uno necesita llorar
el dicho que dice después de la tormenta
llega a la calma es verdad
después de llorar por un buen rato uno
respira y se siente aliviado inclusive
no está mal desbordar emociones
tan poquito a poco está bien reprimirlas
es un tema de balance cuando tuvimos que
enterrar al grupo para ese día tenía que
ir a cantar
en ese dicho el show debe continuar a
las instituciones ya trabajar
entonces acuerdo que llega mucha
bacteria medio con café y de ahí me fui
a cantar y la verdad no tenía ganas de
nada
porque no tenía que terminar
y agarre militaban y empecé a cantar y
entré en este mundo paralelo
en donde me abstraigo
estoy comunicando estoy cantando tenía
que cantar canciones alegres
y no podía desbordar la tristeza que
sentía
y la música me dio un montón
cuando la persona me ha fallado
que han sido muchas veces la música
siempre están
de sonidos en todas partes
la música no te decepciona no te juzga
la música siempre siempre está y la
música no muere porque va pasando de
generación en generación tengo alumnos
en primer grado de primaria el segundo
que me entregan celoni es el mismo
puedes cantar lo peor de todo de río
en la música también se siente no
solamente se escucha la música sus
vibraciones y uno la siente
y yo ahora le voy a proponer un reto
esto es un diario musical
luego es una pregunta
si usted después en una canción el día
de hoy en este momento por todo lo que
están pasando en su vida hoy qué canción
sería another y cada día hablan de ese
ejercicio y de repente cuando ya tengan
varias canciones arman sus listas de
reproducción
y pueden pasar semanas pueden pasar
meses pueden pasar años y ustedes
regresan a leer esto y se van a dar
cuenta de muchas cosas
la música tiene ese poder es la música
cambió mi vida y también puede cambiar
la vida de ustedes es una herramienta
perfecta para todo en todos lados hay
sonido a todos lados de música si está
manejando con el estrés el tráfico de
clima que se escucha música
cuando estoy trabajando bueno
la música son patrones rítmicos que se
repiten son ciclos al igual como
nosotros nuestras vidas son cíclicas
nuestras emociones son cíclicas a veces
estamos arriba les estamos
y como él dijo lo difícil no es terminar
terminar nuestro triste inclusive
pero comenzar
el obstáculo mayor la música está en
todas partes no muere pasa de generación
en generación
y la música sana
por elías
y lo difícil como les dije no es
terminar el comenzar
y cuando uno comienza
vuelven a empezar
todos los días
es un nuevo comienzo
[Música]
no puedes comenzar sin antes terminar
no puedes caer sin empezar de levantar
no puedes alumbrar si no llevas una luz
lo más difícil es
volver a empezar
tu casas el camino sigue tu destino tu
corazón te viera
no del s
si no llega lo que quieres empieza a
cantar
no puedes comenzar
sin antes terminar
no puedes
sin empezar te levantar
no puedes alumbrar si no llegas una
lo más difícil es
volver a empezar
no puedes comenzar
mirando hacia atrás
no puedes avanzar sin empezar
[Música]
todo tras volar
lo más difícil es
bolden
e
esa
y volver a caminar
[Música]
si no llevas un año
podría empezar
joder al caminar
[Música]
[Aplausos]